اما الان في مع نشره اخبار اللمسك اليوميه
واللي بيتصدرها عنوان طرد الموظفين من
تويتر خاصه بعد تقارير امس لبلومبرج قالت
انه اليوم الاثنين ماسك رح يسرح مجموعه
جديده من الموظفين وتحديدا من اقسام
المبيعات والشركات لكن الان احنا ما شفنا
اي شيء من هذه الاخبار او انباء عن اقالات
جديده على ارض الواقع لكن اللافت حقيقه
انه وسط هذه الدراما والدوامه والعاصفه
اللي شغاله هذه كلها
على الاخر يعني الرجال جالس في الساعات
الماضي على حسابه عادي ولا على باله بينقط
وبيضحك واخر من استلمهم تريقه وهم شبكه
السي بي اس لانه السي بي اس كانت اعلنت من
كم يوم اذا بتذكره انه راح توقف نشاطه على
تويتر
بحساباتهم كلها على تويتر استلمهم ونشر
الصوره اللي شايفينها وعنوانها حبنا اللي
ما بيموت وفيها رجال يعني كاتب على راسه
انه بيحضن ماسك او رجع الكاتب على راسه سي
بي اس تحديدا وبيحضن ماسك وبيقول له
الليمو قادر اتخلى عنه يعني بيتمسخر يعني
انه مو قادر على فراق او انه سيباس مش
قادر على فراق تويتر بس كمان نكت على انه
تويتر حاليا في العالم تعليقات على موضوع
عين كاس العالم ورجعت ترامب وعلى هذا
الموضوع نشر فيديو بيتخيل حال سيرفرات
تويتر امام من ترافيك اللي مو طبيعي
[موسيقى]
رجعت ترامب على تويتر
ولا حتى لشرح اللي فيها اللي يحب يروح
يشوفها على حساب لكن بمناسبه الحديث عن
رجعت ترامب صار عليه اكثر من 87 مليون
متابع وترامب قبل الحظر من سنتين كان
حسابه عليه 88 مليون متابع يعني باختصار
في اقل من 48 ساعه جمع تقريبا نفس عدد
المتابعين اللي جمعهم في 11 سنه يكونوا
فتح حساب للمره الاولى في
2009 واذا خلصنا من اخبار مصر
من بعد ما كان حسابهم حضر من شهر ونص
تقريبا
وشوفنا بيغرد تست بس انه يعني بيختبر
الحساب رجع او لا وبعدها بكم ساعه غرت
ثاني بكلمه واحده بس عملت جدل كبير فكتب
شلوم اللي معناها سلام بالعبري يعني واحد
متهم بمعاداده الساميه بغرد بالعبري في
اول يوم حسابه يرجع فيه يعني تغريده غير
مفهومه ومقصد غير مفهوم لكن على الاقل
خلينا نقول ان الغموض والغرابه هذه مو
غريب عن شخصيتكانيه اللي سمعته من الاسباب
او اللي سمعته مو الاسباب حتى هذه كلها
اللي اتكلم عنها الاسباب الوحيده التي
تصدر ثاني الاخبار في الساعات الماضيه
لانه كمان اعلن عن ترشح للرئاسه امريكا في
20 24 ف خلال اللقاء حصري له مع قناه على
يوتيوب وطالع معه في اللقاء شخص اسمه ما
هيكون مدير حملته ولما نسال هذا اعلان
رسمي رد مايلو وقال نعم للتذكير كان يرشح
نفسه وترف 2020 ونجح فيه طرح اسمه رسميا
على قناه قوائم التصويت فيه اكثر من ولايه
لكن ما كمل المنافسه بعدها
[موسيقى]